Why does the crow take the chosen undead to Lordran?
Oscar speaks of a prophecy in which the chosed undead must escape the asylum.
It's easy to say that the crow is just a meaningless method of transport,
but perhaps the story is deeper than that.
Gargoyles guard the bell of awakening, bat demons take you from Sen's fortress to Anor Londo,
and snake men are used as guards.
The lords seemed to have the ability to make beasts do their bidding.
There is one goddess in particular who has a powerful link with crows.
Velka.
In Japanese mythology crows are messengers from the gods,
symbolizing divine intervention and guidance on human affairs.
The crow takes you to Lordran where you become manipulated by the gods.
So if we assume that Velka is linked to the giant crow, or IS the crow
we have to ask: Why would she want powerful undead to escape the asylum?
Velka is the goddess of sin,
it's worth noting that she doesn't have a lord soul, but is an actual goddess.
She does not just punish humans,
she has a great degree of influence where the gods are concerned.
And the lords fear her.
Everything related to Velka, and everything that the lords fear,
is locked away in the painted world of Ariamis.
In the painted world there are hundreds of crows,
there are the crowpeople of Velka,
there is the equipment of Velkas partners,
and there are the spells used by her order.
Most importantly however, the painted world holds everything that the lords fear.
It holds the occult ember, and the half-dragon Priscilla.
Both of which are lethal to the lords.
So with all this information we are left guessing the allegiance of Velka.
Why is she taking undead from the asylum to Lordran?
The vow of silence miracle describes Velka as a rogue deity,
suggesting she has no allegiance save the hunting down of sinners.
Perhaps by taking you to Lordran she is unleashing you upon the gods for their sins.
The chosen undead certainly is a nightmare for any gods he encounters,
attacking them relentlessly until he succeeds, not even letting death stop him.
I think having someone unkillable come at you over and over again is pretty good punishment.
Perhaps Velka is on Gwyndolin's side,
Gwyndolin is the leader of the darkmoons, who hunt down sinners inside Velka's book of the guilty.
Gwyndolin wants to find worthy undead to link the flame,
and Velka could simply be a part of that, since she chooses powerful undead from the asylum through her crow.
Interpretation number 3 is your own interpretation.
I can't say I'm right and I can't say you're wrong, because the game is open-ended and it's fun to speculate.
So based on this information, do you think Velka has a hidden role in the plot?
Is she playing her hand from behind the scenes? Why?